How many chemo drug types are there to treat pancreatic cancer and do you think
low dose chemo treatments work better than normal dose? Well I'm not an
oncologist or a pharmacologist so I don't know how many chemo drug types there
are to treat pancreatic cancer so I apologize I can't answer that but I know you
could just probably Google that and get a you know a fairly fair statement
about that. Do I think low dose chemo treatments work better than normal dose? No, I don't
think they work better. I think they can be better for some people so why let's
let's rephrase that maybe. Why would a person want to do low dose chemo
insulin-potentiated chemo therapy is what we're talking about? Versus doing regular
full-dose chemo. What are the pros and cons of that? I'm just giving you my
opinion. So the pros of doing full-dose chemo is if you could tolerate it and
immediate is it well tolerated? You know the side effects of it is a
destroy your body. That to me that that would make more sense because you are
going to hit it hard and you have a better chance of really docking yourself
into remission. The problem is is that many people don't tolerate many type of
the truth is let's just be honest a lot of people that do chemo are killed by the
chemo is what killed them the chemo was their demise that's what brought their
body down. I shouldn't say many there's a percentage okay so a percentage whatever
percentage that is no one will ever find that dated because they'll never do a
very steady about that but there is a percentage of people that the chemo is their
demise but that's really not everybody. You know it's people with more
compromised immune systems people with more compromised health people with
co- other co-orbidities people with you know compromised detoxification
pathways from a genetic perspective and tissue injuries perspective let's say
they you know consume more alcohol than they should have in their life they
were exposed to more toxins than they should have in their life so they have
damaged to the liver already and they have a compromised liver they're not
going to be able to detoxify the chemo well or people that just have a genetic
predisposition that they don't detoxify the chemo well they have defects on
they're in a tea pathways they're cytokine P450 pathways in their chronic
pathways a lot more than more people than other people do so there's
compromise there they don't detoxify it well they're gonna have more issues with
chemo but there's some people that detoxify it very well and they could go
through chemo and they can sell through pretty well those people you know tend to
have you know better results with the chemo also there's cancers that don't
respond to chemo I don't care how much chemo in a person to tolerate the
cancer doesn't respond to the chemo if that's the case that it's not gonna
respond to instant potentiated low dose chemo either so if your cancer doesn't
respond to full dose not gonna respond to instant potentiated chemo and let's
they're using it completely different drug so you that would be something
that's common to both but there's some people that just don't tolerate chemo or
they believe they're not gonna tolerate chemo well and some of the
indications are well I don't detoxify any drugs well I'm not good with any drugs
it seems like I just don't I react to them it seems like you know I can't I
can hardly take Tylenol with when I'm feeling sick you know I just know I don't
detoxify medications well at all I don't think I'll do well with chemo those are
the people that would you know that where low dose insulin potentiated chemo
therapy would be a perfect fit because you're giving it about 10% of the dose
of normal dose chemo while doing a insulin push beforehand which will cause the
cancer to help uptake the chemotherapy better thereby you could use a lower
dose that's a whole idea of insulin potentiated chemo therapy well it's not
while it's not potentiated chemo therapy sounds real great to do it has some
negatives things as well number one is what I already spoke of the cancer isn't
going to respond to any chemo therapy it's not gonna respond to the insulin
potentiated low dose chemo therapy either the other negative is you have to use
duo in a far more sessions so usually unfortunately because there's few and far
between clinics that actually administer insulin potentiated chemo therapy you
have to travel to a place typically in Arizona there's another place in Michigan
that doesn't you have to travel there and stay there so you have to basically go
there and you know read the condom for three months because that's how long
you're gonna be there doing it so that's a negative in a way because well I'm
trying to save my life so that's not a negative well that's okay but you're
gonna be away from home if you have little kids at home it's very difficult to
approach your family and do something like that so that's a negative the
positive is you're not gonna get a sick you still can lose your hair you can still
have side effects but you're not gonna get nearly as sick as you would if you were
doing full dose chemo therapy so there's pros and cons to each one so I wouldn't
say it's something works better I'd say it's it's a different application that fits
different people's needs better so that would be the answer to that question I